I spy with my little eye
Democrats threatening our republic as
the Muller investigation into Roger
stones niece's Lemonade Stand from 1996
enters into its fifth decade the White
House is finally pushing back as it
should because the more we learn about
the rush investigation the clearer it
becomes that it's a force initiated by
Barack Obama's corrupt crooked machine
administration we will analyze the facts
as they stand today they seem always to
be changing but we'll analyze what we
have then Google stops telling its
employees not to be evil we're gonna
analyze what that means for
conservatives Starbucks goes full
homeless shanty what that says about our
culture and the incredible stories of
American soldiers escaping Nazi occupied
France on this day in history and if we
have time we'll talk about the Royal
Wedding gosh it was awful I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today beginning with
just eviscerating the Obama
administration day after day we realize
how corrupt and crooked all of them
right up to the top where we'll also be
joined later by Carol Engel every at the
author alongside 94 year old world war 2
captain George Starks of a new book the
coffin corner boys one bomber ten men
and their harrowing escape from
nazi-occupied France really enjoyed it
before we get to any of that let's talk
about hair let's talk about hair you
know I'll tell you guys I love keeps
keeps is a great product wonderful
sponsor the show they help keep the
lights on they help keep hair on your
head
I am not exactly a giant adonis of a man
you know I'm a relatively moderate sized
fella I never played on the football
team or anything like that but I was
always not doing so terrible with the
ladies because I have big poofy thick
hair you've got to keep your hair it's
designed for guys keeps for guys who
want to stop hair loss with their
scientific and affordable approach
managed entirely on keeps calm keeps is
the easiest way to stop hair loss before
it's too late
there are two aspects here one it really
does work a lot of these products
promise everything in the world and they
don't work but keeps really does work
keeps offers the only two fda-approved
hair loss products clinically proven to
keep the hair you have no BS just
science the other aspect here is it's
completely safe there are generic
versions of medications that have been
around for a long time but these are way
way cheaper way easier to get most guys
start to lose their hair two-thirds of
guys by the time they're 25 to 35 for
five minutes now you just go on it's
five minutes that's a dollar a day or
less you'll never have to worry about
hair loss again do it seriously guys
sign up takes less than five minutes
these are the generic versions of the
only two fda-approved hair loss products
out there 10 to 35 dollars a month stop
hair loss today the easy way with keeps
and now get your first month free don't
say I never did nothing for you you know
my weddings coming up and I'm giving you
a wedding present I don't know I'm a
very generous fella to receive your
first month of treatment for free go to
keeps calm / co' FFA co v fe fe co feffy
also that's a good stimulant for hair
too that is ke
pS calm /ko FFA Co V Fe Fe Fremont the
treatment keeps calm / Co FFA keeps hair
today hair tomorrow okay so there is a
lot going on here you might have seen
the tweet over the weekend from Donald
Trump President Trump tweeted out he
goes quote I hereby demand and will do
so officially tomorrow that the
Department of Justice look into whether
or not the FBI
/ DOJ infiltrated or surveilled the
Trump campaign for political purposes
and if any such demands or requests were
made by people within the Obama
administration now this caused me to
remember one of my favorite Obama tweets
he tweeted this a while ago it's just
the absolute incredible troll levels of
Barack Obama
it's a photo it's a photo of him with a
magnifying glass looking in at a girl
and then the tweet just says I spy dot
he told you right there you know as he
said he did it he so he tweets that were
finally Donald Trump is getting really
hard I think the timing here is
important but for a long time we've been
told look the Moller investigation it's
just the FBI they're not politically
motivated its objective they're just
trying to get to the facts nobody is
politically motivated here come nobody
is stealing the election comp nobody's
blah blah blah
in fact when Donald Trump suggested on
the campaign trail that there might be
some shenanigans going on behind the
scene Hillary Clinton vigorously denied
those rigged election claims here is
campaign Hillary it's horrifying you
know every time Donald thinks things
you're not going in his direction he
claims whatever it is is rigged against
him the FBI conducted a year-long
investigation into my emails they
concluded there was no case he said the
FBI was rigged this is a mindset this is
this is how Donald thinks and it's funny
but it's also really troubling really
troubling terrifying horrifying by the
way we'll get into how the FBI handled
Hillary versus how the FBI handled
Donald Trump because it is night and day
and it's total evidence that Hillary
Clinton was lying for her
it's ironic of course because
immediately after the election she says
it's all rigged it's all terrible this
wasn't even a one off line this wasn't
even just something she said on on the
debate stage Hillary Clinton kept
lecturing people here she is at our
campaign rally on Wednesday night Donald
Trump did something no other
presidential nominee has ever done he
refused to say that he would respect the
results of this election now make no
mistake by doing that he is threatening
our democracy look if you lose an
election I've lost elections you don't
feel very good the next day do you but
we know in our country the difference
between leadership and dictatorship
right what she didn't tell you is that
she's the dictator it kind of sounds in
that limp like she's saying you know I
prefer democracy no no because
immediately after the election when she
lost she went you know before she said
well look this sometimes people lose you
got to lose you got to deal with it then
after she lost I believe she said if I
could quote correctly there was I might
be paraphrasing she starts to blame
everybody she says that Russia rigged
the election she undermines the
legitimacy of that election she implied
that it was illegitimate what is she
doing now we're now what two years in
almost two years in she keeps flying
overseas criticizing the administration
criticizing Donald Trump saying you know
that he's undermining the us on the
world stage that she doesn't support the
policy of her own country really
unpatriotic stuff she's one of the best
among them as far as undermining the
Republican administration goes she's
positively restrained compared to other
leading Democrats her husband's former
Vice President Al Gore he just recently
told a University of Maryland graduates
at their commencement that Donald Trump
needs to be removed from office forcibly
here is and I
get it there are I know a great many
supporters a president Trump in this
audience I do understand that as one of
his supporters put it on television he
said the way I look at it
Donald Trump is chemotherapy for America
well in medicine and in science some
experiments are terminated early for
ethical reasons zing good one al you get
it terminated early for ethical reasons
so not a great joke didn't really land
but also interesting to hear he says I
know some of you support the president
were a University of Maryland this is
not exactly a conservative campus you
know big state school East Coast and yet
when he said that people people start
cheering your yeah your your right buddy
because Donald Trump is doing well he's
got good approval ratings everything is
going well domestically and overseas
other than the ginned up controversy is
that the federal bureaucracy and the
Democrats keep trying to throw on him
but in reality things are going very
well but then he says sometimes in
science treatment has to be terminated
early for ethical reasons now what do
you say he's trying to make a joke he's
also saying something we need to
terminate this presidency early we need
to do it we lost the election but we
can't tolerate that we lost the election
we can't abide that the American people
wanted something but we know it's not
good for them we know it's not good
so we need to terminate it early and
this is part and parcel of Democrats
strategy to try to impeach the president
this is not a conspiracy this is not to
quote Hillary Clinton a vast right-wing
conspiracy Democrats have been speaking
openly and holding press conferences
about how they want to impeach the
president why I don't because they don't
like him because they just don't like
him that much here we have a
representative Steve Cohen talking about
how they're going to impeach the
president I'm proud to stand here with
my friend congressman Gutierrez with
other Congress people who will be here
and announcing that we're introducing
articles of impeachment to remove
to trump from office they will be a I
believe six signatories on the
resolution Democrats only respect
elections when Democrats win that's when
they respect elections Democrats only
respect democracy when Democrats win
democratic elections it's as simple as
that they do not respect the electoral
process in fact the Democrats have been
trying to subvert the electoral process
since long before this election we know
that now they denied it at the time they
lied to our faces at the time all the
way up to the top but now we know that
bombshell information now shows that
Barack Obama's FBI interfered with and
spied on Donald Trump's campaign much
earlier than anybody thought we know
that the FBI planted a spy in the Trump
campaign that we have evidence of them
they've been denying it the whole time
now it just slowly over the last year
and a half it's chiseled away at their
narrative they are liars they have no
credibility when they open their mouths
James Comey Barack Obama Loretta Lynch
when they open their mouths there is no
reason to believe a word that comes out
of them they are public Liars so we know
that we also know that James Comey lied
about when the Russia investigations
started James Comey said that the Russia
investigation began in late July 2016
okay what was that based on in part I
suppose it's based on that steel dossier
which was totally ginned up and paid for
by the Hillary Clinton campaign and by
Democrats so we see collusion there
between the Democrats and the FBI but
now we know that an FBI informant who
has been outed according to reports as
Cambridge University professor Stephen
helper that FBI report informants
started reporting to the FBI in early
July 2016 totally undercuts James Comey
and we know that James Comey lied about
this he says the investigation began in
late July and yet the FBI's informant
they snuck into the Trump campaign to
spy on it
that guy was reporting back to the FBI
by early July the timelines don't add up
who is this guy who is helper professor
helper is a long-standing republican
helper worked in the Nixon
administration the Ford administration
Reagan administration and this guy was
sent in by the FBI to spy on Trump
employee quarter-page and campaign
employee George papadopolis you went in
there and spied on both of those guys
now did he just do it out of the
goodness of his heart no we know that
the FBI paid Halper the federal
government paid alper four hundred and
eleven thousand dollars between 2016 and
2017 to put that in perspective that's
more than the annual salary of the
President of the United States well it's
much more than the annual salary of the
current president the United States who
doesn't take any money for his job he
takes a dollar a year or something but
the president by law is supposed to make
four hundred thousand dollars a year
this FBI informant was paid four hundred
eleven thousand dollars between 2016 and
2017 what was he doing for that why was
the FBI why was the national security
apparatus investing so much money in
this guy this guy who's going in to spy
on the Republican nominees campaign for
president of the United States FBI under
the administration of a Democrat Barack
Obama this guy is being paid a ton of
money to go in and spy on the Republican
now some of the Trump critics even on
the right they can't admit the gross
injustice of all of this nominal
Republican eric erickson who used to run
redstate.com he tweeted out quote so a
question how does one infiltrate a
political campaign is more than a menial
volunteer I mean if someone got on
payroll in the main office and was a spy
that reeks of incompetence on the
campaign's part doesn't Trump only hire
the best people like he is making
excuses for Obama's FBI which is spying
on the Republican campaign this is a
nominal Republican who's doing this he
would have been a good defense attorney
for Alger Hiss
that that is that's crazy what this guy
is a well credentialed former employee
of Richard Nixon Gerald Ford Ronald
Reagan he's a respected academic just
because he's duplicitous
and deceptive doesn't mean that you'd
have to be foolish to speak to him
that's know what that means at all this
guy is a long-standing Republican
political operative he
a guy who's well-respected in academic
circles it I don't think it's crazy to
let that guy in and have some meetings
with him well you don't have to be a
bumbling idiot to do that the story here
is not on the incompetence of the Trump
campaign this guy was a three-time White
House staffer what the story is here is
on the duplicity and the deception of
Barack Obama's national security
apparatus and Barack Obama's
investigative agencies so we know at
this point it's just a side note we know
because this the anti-trump stuff is
crazy
it's craziest from the people on the
right because it totally misses the
point
it absolutely misses the point when
you've got these egregious crimes being
committed by the left and by the federal
bureaucracy and they say yeah but you
know Trump he's a dummy isn't he like
guys what are you talking about what are
you talking about
the Democrats and the federal
bureaucracy are trying to undermine the
duly elected conservative Republican
president United States and you're
taking their side are you kidding me so
we know the official story is BS James
Comey lied John Brennan lied not just
Comey the FBI director John Brennan
CIA director for Barack Obama John
Brennan by the way Barack Obama CIA
director who voted for the Communist
Party nominee for president in 1976
somehow under Barack Obama this guy gets
to be in charge of the CIA that we could
do a whole show on on talk about
incompetence or nefarious motives so
John Brennan Barack Obama's CIA director
he knows that he lied and he's getting
nervous he tweets this out today tweets
Club Senator McConnell and speaker Ryan
if mr. Trump's continues along this
disastrous path you will bear major
responsibility for the harm done to our
democracy you do a great disservice to
our nation and the Republican Party if
you continue to enable mr. Trump's
self-serving actions you getting nervous
there John
is that what's going on you know guys
you sound like you're getting a little
nervous why would you be getting nervous
because John Brennan Obama's CIA
director said that the Democrat cooked
up steel dossier was not used as the
basis for the Russian investigation he
didn't know anything about it I don't
know anything about that still does yeah
except we later found out he
know about the seal dossier and he
talked to a lot of people about the
steel dossier and he was spreading it
all around DC CNN has even admitted that
the FBI used the dossier as
justification to begin spying on the
Trump campaign even CNN admits that when
CNN admits something damaging to
Democrats you just can't deny it anymore
it is beyond the point at which you can
deny it now still the timelines don't
quite add up do they did the
investigation begin in late July to
begin in early July it looks like it
began at both times some people gave the
go-ahead here some people gave the
go-ahead here it doesn't really matter
because now by the mark my words with
Democrats are gonna try to do is say
there well the Republicans are saying it
began at two different times and so that
doesn't add up the fact that you can
point to two different times when it
officially began and the official
statements of Obama administration
employee is saying what began here it
began here at began here what it really
points out is that broadly speaking the
Obama administration was determined to
help Hillary Clinton and hurt Donald
Trump how are they gonna do it they're
gonna send in spies to the Trump
campaign they'll do that that's one way
and then okay we got this dossier that
Hillary funded okay we're gonna go we're
gonna use that we're gonna but we're
gonna get him we're gonna go get him
because that's how Barack Obama used his
government Barack Obama I know this I'm
a member of an organization that was
targeted by Barack Obama's IRS a
relative relative ly right-wing
organization nonprofit organization I
was targeted by Barack Obama's IRS while
he was targeting many others he did it
because he used the government to get
his political opponents looks like he
did the same thing here Bill Clinton met
with then Attorney General Loretta Lynch
on her airplane while that plane was
parked at the Phoenix tarmac walks on
the plane later they say oh we were just
talking about our grandkids
so really the former president met with
the sitting Attorney General who's about
to investigate his wife for deleting
federal records and mishandling
classified material you guys were just
talking about your grandchildren right
that's what you're doing you know
they're good okay anything else we're
gonna talk now I guess not I don't get
walks off the plane no way when that
meeting leaked because they tried to
hide it from the public when that
meeting leaked the FBI scrambled to
identify and punish
to source of the leak that's according
to another leak that came out last
December and a leak not reported by the
white right-wing press that was even
reported by Newsweek we know that
happened James Comey admits that he
exonerated Hillary Clinton before the
FBI interviewed her he admits that in
his new book not a conspiracy he's had
to admit it because the facts did not
match his narrative how about the first
draft of his letter exonerated Hillary
Clinton's the first draft of that
accused her of gross negligence because
obviously she was grossly negligent she
mishandled a ton of classified material
and then she bleached all of the all of
the materials a later draft changed that
phrase to extremely careless grossly
negligent became extremely careless why
is that because gross negligence can
mean prison time and fines and the
politicized Barack Obama administration
and Barack Obama's FBI James commis FBI
didn't want that to happen James Comey
also admitted that he publicized that
second letter that October letter so
that Hillary's inevitable regime would
not be illegitimate he didn't do it to
hurt Hillary he did it because he knew
that she was gonna win and he wanted to
give her all the political advantages he
could going into her administration that
is the Obama FBI the Obama DOJ we know
that Hillary Clinton mishandled emails
we don't know what kind of graft she was
covering up because she wiped her
servers she'd destroyed federal Records
with bleach bit and we know from Peter
struck that FBI official we know from
his texts that a redacted source writes
quote the right the White House is
running this the White House is running
this with regard to investigations in
Donald Trump we have it in those texts
ari fleischer tweeted it out today the
former press secretary for George W Bush
tweeted out hey how come no one's
talking about this the FBI said the
White House is running this advant
investigation this Muller investigation
has gone on forever I think at this
point they legitimately are
investigating manna forts cousins
sisters nieces lemonade stand that she
had in Long Island in 1982 that's what
that's all they're going for the Muller
investigation that's going on forever
it's clear that he doesn't have a
smoking gun you know and
photo of Donald Trump and Vladimir
Putin's sunning together in Cabo the the
satire website resistance hole ran a
headline this and boom we've got you
Donald Trump a 13th century tapestry
from Franciscan monks shows Trump and
Putin colluding together is that you
know that's what they're going on
they're going after totally irrelevant
things and this investigation now has
unfettered anti constitutional power
it's naked ly political there's no more
pretense that this is unbiased that it's
nonpartisan it's just about law and
order and patriotism that's what we've
been told it is naked ly political it
always has been
everything relating to Barack Obama is
naked ly political he's never done
anything that isn't politics it's all
politics the GOP would ignore this at
its own peril
we cannot abide this fiction any more
that this is oh that's unbiased oh
that's okay they've been gunning for the
Republican nominee since before he was
the Republican nominee or right around
the time that he was they've been
gunning for him they've been using every
excuse in the book it's naked Lee
political and we need to fight back
speaking of institutional wickedness
Google has now this is like a caricature
of his story
Google's old motto from its code of
conduct used to be don't be evil don't
be evil okay that's pretty funny you
know hahaha whatever they've repealed
that code google now you know it censors
conservatives and has all of our data
and does a very spooky organization they
they now don't say don't be evil they've
replaced don't be evil with do the right
thing okay
I think what's the big deal that tells
us a lot don't be evil a very simple
they had it for its entire existence
decades of existence then do the right
thing huh do the right thing is much
more Machiavellian do the right thing as
mummy is what do the right thing says
implicitly is that sometimes evil things
maybe can be good it's a sort of
situational ethics don't be evil they
thought that don't be evil didn't get at
what they were trying to do said do the
right thing okay
do the right thing means sometimes you
got to break a few eggs to make an
omelet get a little bit evil what it
also says though is that Google is
becoming more overtly sjw social justice
warrior overtly progressive it's not
don't be evil it's not just be an umpire
don't do bad things you can't just stand
by now according to them you've got to
actively push this sjw agenda the social
justice warrior agenda and it's
happening we see it happening ourselves
we see it when they censor The Daily
wire now when you search for Daily wire
articles you get Snopes results and
PolitiFact results fact of left-wing
fact checkers that's oh no you don't
want to read The Daily wire that oh
they're right-wing you don't read the
left-wing one instead that's better they
don't do this to left-wing websites they
do it to the to right-wing websites
YouTube which is owned by Google censors
us all the time I mean we're constantly
my episode last week I don't even
remember what I was talking about I was
talking about some Democrat corruption
and it just cut off right in the middle
they just censored they said we can't
let this guy keep talking they
constantly D monetize conservative
videos they constantly censor
conservative speech Dennis Prager did a
video about how you should not murder on
the Ten Commandment series they said no
this isn't suitable for college students
no can't do it can't do it expect more
of this to come obviously they've been
pushing a progressive narrative for a
long time at Google now they're being
evert about it they're admitting it it's
only gonna get worse speaking of great
things getting worse Starbucks Starbucks
is going full homeless camp now so you
remember earlier this month a black man
was arrested at Starbucks and this
became a big hullabaloo and the reason
he the police were called I suppose he
wasn't arrested the police were called
and it's because these guys came in and
were just sitting at the table and after
a while one of the employees came up and
said hey you have to purchase a product
in order to sit and use our space you
can't just sit here this isn't like a
public park you've got to buy our
product to be here they said no which
are you kidding me you go how rude and
ridiculous you go and you buy the
product but they said no we're not gonna
some multiple
times they come always say hey you know
you gotta buy something he said no they
asked them to leave and they said no
like bartleby the scrivener no I'd
prefer not to no I prefer not to so
eventually they call the police and this
became some big big news story as though
as though it's horrifying that an
employer that a store says you have to
buy their product to be in their space
anywho Starbucks instead of saying hey
guys you have to buy our product to be
in our space they're now saying no no
you don't need to buy anything you can
hang out here you can use our bathrooms
anybody who's in our space even if they
don't buy a product their customers
which just isn't true because customer
has a definition again as Starbucks
can't change the definition of a word
this is a customer hasn't meaning that
isn't true but they're fighting against
reality and so it's about these
bathrooms you can use the bathrooms even
if you don't buy anything why is it that
these days all political fights are
about bathrooms that is really weird
isn't it the transgender bathroom the
Starbucks bathroom why is that
I actually think because it's about who
can use which bathrooms who gets to use
it and who decides who gets to use it is
it the people who own the bathroom or is
it the mob which is it who decides who
gets to use the bathrooms and what we've
decided is the mob does it that's the
that's the progressive political views
the mob gets to decide who gets to use
your property the other thing is
exclusiveness because exclusive litmus
is now considered a bad thing if it's a
men's bathroom that means that it's not
a woman's bathroom and if it's a woman's
bathroom it means it's not a men's
bathroom but some men think that they're
women or very much want to be women or
just are culturally influenced to dress
up like women and so they want to use
the women's bathroom but they can't use
the women's bathroom because they're not
women because they're men that became a
major political fight Barack Obama fan
those flames Donald Trump did not he
said for the five people who are
genuinely confused about your gender
keep doing what you're doing for
everyone else stop acting like a dummy
it's this exclusiveness why well what
you're saying I have to buy a product to
use a space that's all that's exclusive
some people don't have three dollars for
a lot
or her don't you know want to spend
their $3 on a latte the correct answer
to that is then you don't get to use the
space because that's the price of entry
but in the modern progressive democratic
idea of things oh how dare you could
never say that you could no women want
to go to the men's room men want to go
to the women's room probably more the
latter Oh vagabonds want to use the
bathroom at Starbucks and make it much
worse for everybody because it'll just
become a homeless camp no you have to do
that how could you say no how could you
say no and this brings us to the final
point before I bring on our guest
speaking of exclusiveness and nice
things degrading themselves we got it I
will just talk briefly about the Royal
Wedding is Americans love the Royal
Wedding got a lot of viewership in the
u.s. especially women love the Royal
Wedding they love it because we all like
a fairy tale and women in particular
like the story of a princess marrying
Prince Charming this has always been
true at all places in the world in all
cultures forever and now we pretend to
ourselves because of feminism that we're
not allowed to like this anymore so
Disney says no more princesses falling
in love with princes they're gonna not
you know that movie Moana doesn't even
have a prince or some of the love
stories are about sisterly love now or
motherly love they try whatever they can
to resist this traditional story and it
happened at the Royal Wedding Road
wedding it was really awful to watch I'm
sorry to say I think I'm the only person
who's actually saying this I bet a lot
of people thought it though which is
you're interesting George's Chapel
you're in the aristocracy you're in the
monarchy and it opens up on Benny King's
stand by me stand by me at the Royal
Wedding and it's not that I don't like
stand by me that's a nice song I also
like Van Morrison and and David Bowie
but I don't think that David Bowie
should be played at a royal wedding you
know I think maybe you opened up with oh
Jesus we adore there some Anglican him
you know so they had that aspect then a
woman who Megan mark old the new Duchess
of Sussex who was who walked down the
aisle and married another man seven
years ago till death do us part that
till death do us part turned out to be
till two years from now to his part so
five years ago she was married to
another man and yet she walked down in
white I don't begrudge her her divorce
when you get married in a church that
was found
by the most famous divorcee in all of
history Henry the eighth that doesn't
get to be a big issue but even that the
force of it to walk down as though it
just punctures some of the magic of the
fairy tale then when they walked out it
the song that was playing was edit James
this little light of mine again a lovely
song not appropriate for the English
monarchy for this high church wedding
they walked out of there megan has a
website now in the royal page that says
she's proud to be a feminist oh gosh
this that the monarchy wants to
modernize that's what all of the
mainstream media are reporting how good
it is that we have a modern monarchy
nobody wants a modern monarchy if you
modernize the monarchy you don't make it
better you just destroy the monarchy
because the monarchy is aristocracy
aristocracy comes from aristos which is
Greek for the best right is the best
it's supposed to elevate you it's not
supposed to reflect the people that's
democracy demos the people democracy
reflects the people the spirit of the
age Aristo s-- represents the virtues
and the best the monarchy is supposed to
be something to look up to to elevate
the people if you modernize it and make
it reflective of the people you don't
get a better monarchy you just get
another democracy and it's cheap and
it's weird and it's not a fairy tale
Disney is doing it the British royal
family is doing it both of them should
stop it's very frustrating we've got to
get to this day in history and our
wonderful guests before we get to that
I've got a second bite of Facebook in
YouTube we got a really good yesterday
we're gonna hear about some incredible
stories escaping Nazi occupied France
during World War two but if you are on
Facebook or YouTube you got to go to
daily wire.com right now why well it's
ten bucks a month 100 dollars for annual
membership you get me you get the
underlayment show you get the Ben
Shapiro show you can't ask questions in
the mailbag everybody can listen to the
mailbag questions but only subscribers
can ask them many are called few were
chosen you get to ask questions in
conversation everybody can watch but
only subscribers get to ask the
questions next one up is the big boss
ben shapiro who's away right now i
talked a little bit more about the royal
wedding on Drew's show today which
became the ben shapiro radio show and
i'm sure that will be hilarious when Ben
comes back in a fury that I was on his
show while he was gone that's a story
for another time
go to tell me why you're calm we'll be
right back with this day in history and
you can return with your leftist here's
tumbler yum-yum-yum
on this day in history a lot of things
happen in World War two in 1940 a
special unit in Germany carried out a
mission and murdered more than 1500
hospital patients in Prussia this was an
attack to kill the unfit those people
deemed unfit by the scientifically
barbaric German government and Nazi
government by the way that special unit
reported back to headquarters in Berlin
that the patients had been successfully
evacuated I suppose they were
successfully evacuated to their eternal
reward but they were murdered in cold
blood on earth in 1942 on this day in
history 4,300 Jews were deported from a
Polish town to a Nazi camp at Sobibor
and all were gassed to death that camp
had five gas chambers quarter of a
million Jews were killed there between
1942 and 1943 the German firm IG Farben
set up factory outside of Auschwitz and
on this day in history 1940 the French
ninth army surrendered this you might
know I'm waving the flag of the French
army right now as a matter of fact the
French army surrendered itself as a
nation France would surrender within the
month we're lucky enough today to be
joined by Carol Engel Everett the author
alongside of world war ii veteran
captain george starks of coffin corner
boys one bomber ten men and their
harrowing escape from nazi-occupied
France it is a wonderful read Carol
thank you for being here
well thank you for having me Michael
Carol so this book for just to give a
little overview of it the book tracts 20
year old George Starks on a 300 mile
trek to Switzerland he's got a fractured
foot there he'd been shot down over Nazi
occupied France he's got a 20 millimeter
shell fragment in his thigh he comes
face to face with Nazis he's barely
evades capture and yet these days 20
year olds suffer nervous breakdowns when
their parents forget to upgrade their
iPhone data plans how responsible do you
think in your research for this book the
war was for shaping what we now call the
greatest generation well that's how you
raised some interesting questions there
because really
George was 19 when he first got his
pilot's wings so even younger than 20
the average age on that crew was 22
there was one of them that was 27 and
did the rest of them he was ancient so
they called him the old man pops our
Pappy and it was an amazing thing really
because George has often told me all ten
of them were from very different
backgrounds religious backgrounds
different socioeconomic family
situations educational backgrounds
different but they all had one thing in
common they were all Patriots and they
all wanted to go to war to protect
America and so it's a it's an
interesting thing and in fact last week
somebody asked me you know Carroll to
whom did you write this book
well obviously people who enjoy reading
about great heroes and World War two and
all but I have seven grandchildren and I
actually wrote the book for them because
if we don't get these stories down and
recorded we're going to lose them and I
want my young grandchildren I look too
young right now to read it but I want
them to know what these men really did
well I love that point I'm sorry go
ahead
well I just said you know really they
were boys we call the men but but they
were really boys when they got started
of course unfortunately through the
through the war they they grew up very
quickly so well it's the stories aspect
that I really like is there the stories
in this book are incredible and my
grandfather was a navigator on a b24 he
bombed a lot of Nazis of war and so I
grew up as a kid I grew up hearing these
stories and kids today they don't hear
these stories they'll uh I don't know
what they hear you know a lot of these
veterans are going up to their eternal
reward at a faster clip so the the
people who live through it are leaving
the earth do you think there's a risk
here that these narratives are going to
be lost to history obviously there
aren't a whole lot of
out like yours there certainly aren't
enough how much are we going to remember
in 50 or 100 years well and you know we
we need to get as many recorded as we
can I'm doing my part trying to trying
to get them down this um this one book
does have 10 stories each of the crew
and what happened to them after they
were shot down of course now George
Starks the pilot is the primary person
in the book because he goes he returns
to Europe and later and retraces his
steps and that's a wonderful part of
that story but George is still living
he's 94 and I has turned into a dear
friend it took us about three years to
research the book and for me to
interview him but you know he'll be 95
in November and only one other of the
crew had been alive when I started this
book and that was and actually the only
Jewish member of that crew Irv Baum and
he unfortunately passed away about eight
or nine months ago but I was so
privileged and thankful that I was able
to interview him too before he did
before he did pass away so well and you
know on this point there were these
multiple faith backgrounds people were
virtual I suppose Christian and George
says at one point in the book
I need help god I can't do this by
myself they say there are no atheists in
the foxholes and broadly in the culture
we see that religion is declining and
younger generations appear to be much
less religious than older generations do
you think it's this the suffering of war
trampling through France surrounded by
Nazis with a broken foot that brings out
people's need for God do you think that
was the defining feature well I think
anytime a person comes face to face with
their mortality in a situation where
their life is actually going to be on
the line and might could end at any
moment I think that in and of itself
produces sort of a landscape for
thinking about what may be eternal and
what might not be eternal and George
certainly as he was going along reached
that place that point where he was at
the end of his Road in human terms
and so what he did then was turned to at
that moment what he felt might be a
higher power that could possibly help
him and that's what he did there's a
incredible scene in the book where he it
really literally thinks that he just
cannot go on and he has been without
food for a number of days he's been wet
and cold and you know he's up in in snow
country and he he just calls out he says
God you know I I can't do this on my own
I you're gonna have to help me
so and speaking of speaking of that
higher power and perhaps forgiving your
enemies and loving your neighbor we see
in his later life captain storks and his
wife Betty Joe they go back to France
after the war
they find the civilians who risked their
own lives to save his life and broadly
speaking the United States makes friends
with our enemies after Wars this is a
habit of ours we have a special
relationship with Great Britain although
we fought two wars with them right at
the beginning Germany Japan Vietnam on a
Korea on and on maybe North Korea soon
depending on how this meeting goes next
month yes so I want to know what insight
did you gather from working with Captain
Starks on dealing with your former foes
deal at you know burying hatchets this
guy's lived an incredible life he's seen
the world change dramatically what that
says for us individually and what it
says for US policy well you know really
when he returned to France these were
the people that had helped him
and actually most of the people that he
ran into did help him but he it took him
a long time to hook up this is the this
is the interesting part it took him a
long time to hook up with the actual
organized underground or resistance so
from day one the people that helped him
were just normal average everyday
Frenchman went men men women and
children they were not part of an
organized resistance they just simply
knew that you know they disliked the
Germans for coming in and what they were
doing to their country and they wanted
to do what they could with any American
soldier or ally you know that they ran
into so to me that was the most
incredible thing because these people
had everything to lose
for example the the woman that he stayed
with the very first night okay she had a
little girl who was eight or nine years
old her husband at that time was a peel
w polish POWs with the Germans and had
she been caught there is no question but
what she would have been executed and
probably her daughter as well at the
very least sent to a concentration camp
I mean when they caught as I think you
write in the book when they caught
people who were housing runaway American
soldiers they men women and children
they'd pull him out and they'd shoot
them in the head right exactly so so
when when George was shot down and after
and in this 300 mile trek to freedom in
Switzerland he vowed two things to
himself number one that if he ever if he
made it if he lived through the
experience and got back to the States
he would never lose touch with his crew
again as long as he lived
the second vow that he made to himself
was that at some some point one day if
he could he would go back to France and
try to locate all those brave souls that
had helped him and helped his men and he
live to do both of those things it's an
amazing story it's a really amazing
story and the book achieved something
which i think is really in
credible it really almost makes you like
the French I hate I don't know that I
could even say it on the ship but it
really does I apologize for my French
army flag joke
the book is coffin corner boys it's by
Carol Engle ever yet alongside Captain
George Starks it's a really engrossing
read a really enjoyable and tells a
story that is quickly being forgotten so
read it so you don't forget it go get
the book coffin corner boys Carol thank
you so much for being here you so much
Michael good to be with you today god
bless you too so that was whether it's a
really fascinating to talk to her and a
really fascinating book that's our show
so go read the book out we can talk
about it tomorrow you come back tomorrow
we'll talk about it I listen guys I'm
I'm like getting ready for my bachelor
party I'm getting ready to get married
soon we are you know send me send those
good vibes man thoughts and prayers I
could take him and I will see you
tomorrow get your mailbag questions in
I'm Michael Knowles this is the Michael
Knowles show
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
semia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy board senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you